can a robot have a gender
defend the indefensible
and simply the word water
these are all past questions from what
is often called the hardest exam in the
world
now truly we know that for each of us
the hardest exam in the world is the one
we haven't studied for but this exam
does seem pretty fascinating it is the
university of oxford all souls college
examination fellowship all souls is a
college at oxford and it's very
exclusive if you pass this exam you get
an all expenses paid fellowship to live
there for seven years and focus on your
graduate studies and academic work the
website says that you get seven years in
ideal research conditions in regular
contact with leading scholars in your
field and free from the many pressures
financial or otherwise that can affect
graduate students
in seven years you might be able to
complete a doctorate turn it into a book
and then move on to a new project
now doesn't that sound nice
but every year only one or two students
pass this exam so perhaps don't get your
expectations up too high it's a hard
exam because there are no right or wrong
answers and the questions are somewhat
abstract which makes it the kind of
thing that's difficult to study for
the exam consists of writing 12 essays
over four papers taken over two days
there are two general papers and then
you get a choice from law history
philosophy politics economics english
literature and classics
it's not really one for the scientists
but let's have a look at some of the
past questions
let's take a look at the general paper
is there something to be said for
boredom
should historical fiction keep to the
facts
and are some languages more beautiful
than others there are a lot of past
questions to go through but i'll point
out some of the ones that i found the
most fascinating or that really made me
think
number eight does guilt promote
creativity
in number 10 we see a quote from daniel
kahneman what would i eliminate if i had
a magic wand overconfidence discuss
a lot of the questions though go towards
being a lot more controversial or even
political there are questions in here
about vaccine passports and the gig
economy probably issues that are topical
and being discussed in the media around
the time that the exam is taking place
we've got should genetic enhancement of
intelligence be explored and defend the
indefensible
some questions then would be easier to
study for than others those ones about
current issues it would certainly help
to be on top of what's being printed in
newspapers and online journalism things
like that but some of these more
theoretical or abstract questions
perhaps you just have to hope that it's
something you've thought about before
and perhaps that's an appropriate
strategy to pick questions that you have
already thought about because some of
them for example number 29 are
cryptocurrencies the future it's
plausible you will have seen already a
bunch of youtube videos about that or
otherwise but questions like 22 can a
robot have a gender did make me stop and
think about something that i hadn't
really thought too much about before the
exam is designed to find really smart
people and i guess one kind of smart
person does already in their daily life
talk about and think about a lot of
these questions
should any new science be published
behind paywalls or how can policy combat
algorithmic discrimination
being the kind of engaged member of
society that enjoys a bit of
intellectual challenge perhaps you
already arrive at the exam with thoughts
references quotes relating to some of
these arguments
how will historians study the internet
age
or number 14 write the history of a
color this one seemed pretty fascinating
so i had to think about how i might
answer it even though i don't have a lot
of experience with essays especially at
this level a visit to the wikipedia page
for the colour red provides plenty of
interesting tangents that you might want
to pursue
perhaps i would talk about how it was
one of the first colours ever made and
used in prehistoric art that it was used
in war and pottery and eventually became
a political colour that since red is the
colour of blood it has been historically
associated with sacrifice danger courage
but also passion anger and love
if i was worldly and prepared i would
perhaps show up with some names of
famous paintings that feature the color
red and talk about how color itself is a
way that people can be connected
throughout history even if perhaps not
everyone experiences color in the same
way
since i'm not too well versed in the
more political questions or ones from
other areas of the humanities i'll point
out some of the more sciency questions
because at least they are ones that i
have considered before number 21 is the
turing test a reasonable criterion for
the achievement of general a.i
and keep in mind this isn't really an
exam for the scientists and
mathematicians unless you also happen to
be an expert in one of the humanities
subjects so answering these questions
will have to come from quite a
philosophical and general point of view
rather than just presenting some
scientific information
this question here sort of surprised me
should we bring back woolly mammoths
from the dead because that is a question
that i've seen on essays all the way
back to high school biology so i guess
you're having to present a much more
advanced and nuanced answer here we have
here a quote from carl sagan we live in
a society exquisitely dependent on
science and technology in which hardly
anyone knows anything about science and
technology
does this matter
and that seems like rather a nice
question because instead of just
complaining that people don't know
enough about science you're actually
having to discuss why you think they
should or perhaps why they shouldn't
have to would it matter if newspapers
cease to be printed
are streaming services good for music
and which concept is more fundamental
shape or color
is artificial intelligence already
beyond our control
and i'll be paging john green to answer
is the anthropocene a useful concept
we then have should beauty be taxed
should ugliness be compensated
and in what sense are civil servants
servants
think about whether you could really
write an entire essay about is ignorance
bliss
or defend tweeting
are there too many books this one
probably i've thought about the most
it's just sitting in a library and
looking at all the ones on the shelf
that hardly ever get read and thinking
about the prospect that every day more
books are being published but i'm sure
there's a way to argue that we benefit
from new and updated knowledge all the
time and if we just kept all the books
that we already have that wouldn't be
great either
one for the gamers in the house we have
would you rather be a vampire or a
zombie
is it possible to imagine a society
without law
and then a nice one here number 17
does it matter if we are alone in the
universe
a scientist answering this might just
present things like the fermi paradox
and the drake equation or probabilities
that we are or aren't alone in the
universe and
show some of the ways that we're looking
for life and you know the probability of
finding bacteria here or there but this
question asks does it matter
perhaps you could present the arthur c
clark quote that two possibilities exist
either we are alone in the universe or
we are not both are equally terrifying
and you could write about the history
and impact of merely thinking about this
question how it has impacted the way
that humans think about themselves and
their place on the earth perhaps start
with how our mindsets had to change when
we began to accept the heliocentric
model that the sun is at the center of
the solar system rather than the earth
that we first had to think that you know
everything does not revolve around us
then extend that to as we started to
discover exoplanets and there's a
stephen hawking quote that says that we
are just an advanced breed of monkeys on
a minor planet of a very average star
so we begin to have to think about the
fact that on some of these other planets
that have similar conditions perhaps to
earth that there might be similar kinds
of life but then there's the fact that
we haven't found any of it yet so you
can still talk about the fermi paradox
and how weird that is and perhaps how it
makes us appreciate the rarity or how
precious life is
then if this was my essay perhaps
talking a little bit about the growing
trend of space pessimism in space movies
a lot of the time
space is presented as a lonely space
that the characters often experience
tragedies in and
it's not until they return home to earth
to their families and loved ones that
things tend to come full circle so does
it matter if we are alone in the
universe well maybe it does because the
question itself sort of frames how we
think about exploring space
number 24 down here is should we even
try to understand how the brain works
and i thought that seems like an obvious
answer that we should but perhaps trying
to think of ways to answer this and
present arguments why we shouldn't would
actually be a really interesting
conversation
then as a fitting final question on this
paper number 25 asked
are there any unanswerable questions
before we take a look at some of the
other papers let's take a look at the
assessment criteria for these essays one
is the engagement including the range of
issues addressed
the depth and sophistication of
comprehension and directness of
answering the question you also need to
present a coherent argument that has
clarity and power is intellectual and
original you need to provide information
such as knowledge of the original
sources
range depth and detail of evidence cited
and accuracy of your information it
should be organized and presented well
with clarity and coherence correct
grammar spelling and punctuation and
whoever's reading your answer has to be
able to see a new potential for future
intellectual development there's also an
interesting note here about a dress code
for the exam
men are expected to wear a suit tie and
gown
and women should wear equivalent attire
i'm not sure if this is normal for all
exams at oxford but that sounds like one
of the fanciest looking exams that i've
heard of if you do well on the exam you
might be shortlisted and invited back to
answer questions about the answers you
wrote and this will be in front of all
the fellows that are in the school so
there might be up to 80 people watching
you answer those questions
we can take a little look at the
philosophy questions but i'm guessing
they're going to be pretty difficult
here we go number five a person is a
person
through a person discuss
or can we talk or think about everything
that exists
on the next page we have could rocks be
conscious
and with that i might put away the
philosophy paper and take a look at
another one english literature this one
i wouldn't really stand a chance on
unless i did some serious study and
research or basically took a degree in
english literature because i don't
really know most of the references that
they're talking about here
but in a way it makes me want to study
english literature because like a lot of
the questions on the other papers we
looked at these just seem really
interesting there's this question here
number 17
byron's romanticism it must be confessed
was only half sincere a quote apparently
by bertrand russell and it's about lord
byron ada lovelace's father
write about sincerity or insincerity in
romantic period poetry or what was
transcendental about
transcendentalism that's probably enough
for now
there was one other category of
questions that has since been
discontinued and those were essays where
only one word was given as a prompt so
water originality novelty miracles those
are all previous questions
it certainly is a very fascinating exam
and even if you have no intention of
ever sitting at yourself at least some
of these questions would make for
interesting topics of discussion or
debate hopefully not too heated though
thanks for watching this video and
thanks to my patreon supporters who make
my content possible
a special shout out to today's patreon
cat of the day ashley
[Music]
you